from food manufacturers to hospitality
car plants to haulage builders merchants
police control rooms
and supermarket shelves the end of
lockdown
has brought partial shutdown to british
business
the rise in covid cases matched by
soaring numbers instructed to
self-isolate
by the nhs test and trace app a record
618
000 last week alone including almost all
of the staff
at some builders yards of 12 people
who would normally operate in the yard
um only two of them are actually working
so 10
of the 12 have been asked to
self-isolate
so we know that there are a number of
people that are being asked to stay at
home
who quite simply don't have any symptoms
and aren't ill across industry there are
calls to bring forward the date from
which the double vaccinated can take
tests instead of isolate
but after a week of mixed messages
ministers are resisting
my point is that the restrictions
fingers crossed will be lifted on the
16th of august i'm confident they will
be but i can't guarantee that but
can we limp along until then um i think
we're going to have to follow the rules
until the 16th of august i know it's a
long time but it's not going to last
forever
and i think that once the restrictions
are lifted we can get back to normality
supermarkets are hiring thousands of
temporary staff to fill staffing gaps
and those on the shelves social media
users sharing images that may have been
compounded
by an ongoing hgv driver shortage and
the hot weather
many of the businesses that are being
impacted have shared
data on their absence rate those pockets
of issues with the government
and they're looking at that right now so
our hope is that over the coming hours
that they will shift that position
because obviously what none of us want
to see is is
increased disruption over the coming
days supermarkets say that
self-isolation rules have interrupted
distribution but not
underlying food supplies and there's no
need to panic by but they
and thousands of other businesses and
hundreds of thousands of people
are going to have to live with
disruption for at least
another month as a price of dropping
all the other covered restrictions part
of the solution may lie here
aperitito make food for care homes and
hospitals
and are running one of 20 government
test and release trials
in which pinged staff take daily tests
to allow them to work
instead of isolate i think testing alone
isn't the answer the real focus here is
on prevention and prevention of
transmission and that's where i think
covered safety measures you know
relentless focus on social distancing
face coverings one-way systems
segregated work is a key
i think that the numbers of isolations
are increasing ours are still relatively
low but daily contact testing is
definitely helping
and as those numbers increase it will
become even more valuable
west midlands police have joined those
calling for the rules to be eased
the pandemic proves it's not the app
that's broken down
but social distancing paul kelso sky
news in wiltshire